good morning it gets Tuesday I'm sorry
if this videos a little bit disjointed
the linings of my brain and spinal cord
are inflamed which is pretty
uncomfortable
okay so last week I said on a message
saying that I was gonna miss my vlog for
this video due to hospitalization and
then I went back to being in like the
worst pain of my life and then while I
was staring at the ceiling begging for
the pain to go away the Internet
diagnosed me with Ebola like John Green
Ebola was a trending search on Twitter
people I knew in real life texted me and
were like do they know what it is yet is
it confirmed and I was just like barf
and I don't mean that figuratively so
ten days before getting what turned out
to be viral meningitis I was in Ethiopia
which shares a continent with countries
like Guinea and Sierra Leone where there
is currently an Ebola outbreak now never
mind that Ethiopia is as far from this
outbreak as England is from Afghanistan
I had recently been on the same
continent as Ebola and now I was in the
hospital
ergo Ebola quick sidenote Hank Ebola is
a very serious health crisis in West
Africa but more people are going to die
of malaria today than have died from
Ebola in the last 10 years combined so
anyway when I went to the hospital the
doctors were very concerned I mean I
might have meningitis or malaria or
typhoid or dengue fever all of which can
be fatal but they weren't worried that I
had Ebola this is my point though even
if I had Ebola it wouldn't have been a
big deal well I mean I guess it would
have been a very big deal to like me and
my family it wouldn't have been a big
deal from a public health perspective
like here's what the news would have
said an American has contracted Ebola
shortly after returning from Africa
Ebola Johnny went to Orlando Florida and
signed books for 1600 people at a Harry
Potter convention all of whom are now
veritably dripping with the disease but
here's the thing Hank if I had somehow
magically gotten Ebola in Ethiopia which
to reiterate is impossible I wouldn't
have given it to any of those 1600
people at leakycon for one thing you
aren't contagious if you aren't
symptomatic and also I didn't share
bodily fluids with any of those 1,600
people call me old-fashioned Hank but I
like to keep bodily fluid sharing within
my nuclear family Ebola is spreading
because it's often being treated in
health care facilities with no running
water or latex gloves which makes
sterilization functionally impossible
having water and bleach would prevent a
lot of these Ebola cases this isn't some
terrifying uncontrollable superbug
there's mounting evidence that there
might be treatments or vaccines or both
within a year but the most important
thing to remember heck is that this
outbreak is happening because of poor
health infrastructure Hank I think we're
obsessed with Ebola partly because it's
novel partly because it's so fatal but
partly because most diseases endemic to
the developing world seem other I mean
more than half a million people are
gonna die of malaria this year but
unlike Ebola we don't think of malaria
as a disease that's coming for us
whatever the hell us means now of course
Ebola isn't coming for this vague us
either it's not going to spread widely
in the US or Europe but regardless when
Americans try to make the Ebola outbreak
about America we do a great disservice
to ourselves and the communities
actually affected by this horrible
disease in Liberia and Guinea and Sierra
Leone health workers have to choose
between abandoning their work and
putting themselves and their kids at
risk for Ebola and they have to make
that choice because of inadequate
infrastructure and supplies addressing
that problem instead of freaking out
about the disease coming to whoever us
is will actually reduce Ebola
transmission and in the process it will
also save many many lives from malaria
and typhoid and also meningitis which
brings me back to my infected brain
lining Hank it turns out that I almost
certainly got meningitis not in Ethiopia
but in Florida Oh Orlando city of my
youth city of my enflamed meninges Hank
it's gonna take a little bit for my
meninges to completely D itis so I
apologize if I'm not around quite as
much in the coming weeks the
nerdfighters thank you so much for
putting stuff on your heads to cheer me
up it really did the trick when I
desperately needed it Hank I'll see you
on Friday